a shocking allegation against Nick
Carter sued for sexual assault and the
new Fallout for the Backstreet Boys
welcome to Entertainment Tonight yeah
we're going to get to that but let's
start with GMA anchors TJ Holmes and Amy
robach will their relationships survive
all this drama we've got the latest at
CBS morning's anchor Gail King sounds
off
it's just gotten very messy and very
sloppy
in the beginning I actually thought was
good on Good Morning America they're
saying they're not taking them off the
air to consenting adults but then the
more you read it's just very messy we're
filling in for Amy robach and TJ Holmes
five days straight Amy and TJ benched a
source tells E.T it's still unclear as
to what if any disciplinary action might
be taken but for now both TJ and Amy are
laying low and trying to move on with
life Amy's been spotted out in Manhattan
but where's TJ the GMA anchor who faces
claims of multiple Affairs was last seen
one week ago in Times Square juggling
two cell phones as for their
relationship we're told quote they are
definitely together right now you've got
kids involved you've got families
involved and I keep thinking about that
yeah I I'm very concerned about that the
affairs scandal isn't the only major
controversy facing ABC right now E.T has
confirmed that the network has pulled
the plug on a very Backstreet holiday
the special was scheduled to air
Wednesday but was scrapped after a
sexual assault allegation against Nick
Carter the last 21 years have been
filled with pain confusion
frustration
39 year old Shannon Ruth was in tears
yesterday talking about the alleged 2001
incident he was nasty and threatening
saying I would go to jail if I told
Shannon who has autism and cerebral
palsy claims she was raped by Nick after
a concert in Tacoma Washington she was
17 years old at the time
when the concert ended he invited her to
join him on the tour bus and once they
were inside the bus he gave her a funny
tasting beverage that he called VIP
juice
after my assault I started cutting
myself
just hours after yesterday's press
conference Nick was spotted out waving
to fans in New York he vehemently denies
the allegation his attorney called
Shannon's lawsuit a press stunt adding
this claim about an incident that
supposedly took place more than 20 years
ago is not only legally meritless but
also entirely untrue
okay let's move on to some good news
this morning over at the Today Show Al
is officially home from the hospital
Al who was all smiles went home
yesterday he's been dealing with blood
clots in his leg and lungs I love him
and um
[Music]
foreign